I mean in many respects he's already
rhetorically deployed nuclear weapons
and used them because he's got everybody
scared and running around so we have to
you know bear in mind that that's the
kind of thing he does so how do we get
ahead of it
um one of the um things that uh is worth
bearing in mind for example is that they
take a very careful read of us and about
how we react
so we think about when they move through
the Chernobyl exclusion Zone the the
military forces
Putin was paying attention the fact that
everybody said oh they wouldn't possibly
go through Chernobyl why would they do
that I mean that's just horrific I mean
why would they think about doing that
because of course they go all the way
through and this scared the heck out of
everyone by not just stirring up the
dust the toxic dust that's going to
actually you know probably host of
cancer cases and all of the young
conscripts that were sent through that
but it's it's basically stirs up the
dust of time people like me and you and
others you know remember the Chernobyl
explosion